hello everyone if you enjoy Star Trek
you've probably been waiting to check
out the new Star Trek discovery and the
chances are you've been disappointed I
know I have but as I can't help you with
that I can recommend you to watch or
well I just watched two episodes today
of the starship Orwell and it's it's
surprisingly enjoyable so if you haven't
you know check it out if you like Star
Trek on I'm sure you'll love Orgel but
getting back to this game a couple of
days ago I made a video about a game
between under lilienthal and Rasheeda
Schmidt being off in that game I
mentioned this game it's a famous game
Olivia told versus capablanca and a lot
of you suggested I make a video on it so
here it is it's played in the very
strong Hastings tournament that was
played from 1934 to 1935 and this is
pretty much self-explanatory you hear
Hastings tournament you know it's gonna
be a strong tournament the tournament
was won by Max who a future world
champion
capablanca here got fifth no fourth
place fourth place and Lilienthal got
fifth place a couple Blanco got five and
a half points away got six and a half
and the Lilienthal got five followed by
bhavini who also got five points Vera
main chick also played in this
tournament she got like I think three
points and the one eighth place but in
this game this is the game everyone
wants to see from this tournament so so
let's check it out
kappa blanka has the black pieces and
under opens up with d4 Knight to f6 c4
e6 Knight to c3 and Bishop to b4 the
nimzo-indian defense we have a three
Bishop captures and c3b captures and b6
f3 preparing to meet Bishop f7 with that
nice Center this is the semi variation
we have d5 Bishop to g5 and now h6
Bishop to h4 now bitter to a6 and efore
now and here is a very peculiar moment
in the game for some reason kappa blanka
played Bishop captures on c4 and this
makes really no sense
for example with the D characters on C
for your you're not allowing white to
develop the bishop on d3 or on c4 for
that matter
you're forcing white to go there should
be to Knight to h3 and for some you know
pretty pretty unnatural moves in the
opening and this would have definitely
been better for black but after e4
Capablanca decided to play Bishop
captures on c4 and here you read the
white of all of his troubles he said
Lilienfeld simply played Bishop
characters on c4 and D captors on c4 and
this is by no means a mistake it's more
of an inaccuracy but ok Queen to f4
Czech Queen to d7 and under captures the
pawn queen characters on c4 and white
now has a monster center here so we'll
see how this goes Queen to c6
Blanca offers a trade of Queen's Queen
to d3 and Knight B to d7 Knight to e2 we
have worked to dat lilienthal castles
and a5 there was this threat of the
annoying Queen to a sex going for the a7
pawn so Capablanca immediately fixed
this Queen to c2 getting the Queen out
of that D file were the rookies and
guarding a 4 so Queen to c4 we have f4
now
and rook to see a time pinning the rook
since the knight is pinned so moving the
rook so the knight can move we had F 5
by Lilienthal and now comes B 5 and this
is the this is the famous moment in the
game here D characters on e5 was played
by Lillian doll and kappa blanka played
the Queen captures on e4 offering now a
trade of Queens since the Queen and c2
is unprotected and if you remember in my
video Lilienfeld verses that are she
denies Medina
I mentioned this position that when
Bobby Fischer was playing his a World
Chess Championship rematch against Boris
Spassky in 1992 he so Lilienthal in the
crowd and he greeted him with the remark
he captures on f6 so
given up the Queen the Queen is free for
the taking and c2 and it's not that easy
to decline this you don't really have on
any other
if you play Knight captures on f6 you
see you're simply down a piece okay you
can capture Queen captures on h4 but
after F characters on g7 you have to
move the rook now f6 comes and you're
simply terrible if you capture a knight
f6 Queen to a5 attacking both Knight and
the rook on c8 this is completely losing
for black
so after this he captures on f6 I'm just
gonna show it again here it is e
captures on f6 Queen captures on c2
kappa blanka except the Queen and we
have F captures on g7 only place for the
rook is g8 you can go h7 because the
pawn promotes and here comes Knight to
d4 attacking the Queen here kappa blanka
plate Queen to b4 he allowed this rook
to e1 to 4 to pin the Queen but it
doesn't help if you play something like
Queen to a4 for example then rook the
rook a to e1 is winning the game
immediately 95 you have to block rook
captures King moves now rook did d5
would check the knight is covering here
the point is covering here King has to
go back now comes the rook e1 and this
is checkmate
so after Knight 34 kappa blanka played
Queen to e4 but now rook 81 nice the c5
rook to e4 capturing the Queen back
Knight captures and now rook to e1
pinning the night rook captures on g7
but rook captures on e4 would check we
have king to d7 and in this position 1
kappa blanka played the king 37 he also
resigned to the game okay you do have
two rooks
two rooks I mean you do have two rooks
against the rook and Knight and the
bishop and while this might be playable
it may be some position this position is
actually so good for white it it makes
no sense
white can't seem to play rook to e7
check King has to move now f6 comes you
have to move the rook after Bishop g3
check King moves you grab the f7 pawn
next you're gonna grab the c7 pawn and
this pawn is simply going up the board
winning the game so capablanca decided
there is no point in continuing this
so a brilliant victory and definitely
you know a historic historic game played
between two chess legends Lilienthal and
Capablanca and I think I don't know
probably probably all began here after
this efore move one couple Blanca
instead of D captures and c4 played
Bishop captures and c4 is where his
troubles started so yeah that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
I think y'all for watching and I will
see you soon